In the Amazon we have a universe
of products, for example chanta curo,
products that any
three Michelin star restaurant wants to have in zero. It
is a duty that I have to be able to
show this cuisine
and if I have the opportunity to tell it to the
world that  do
[Music]
my name is juan josé aniceto and I am a
cook specialized in Masonic cuisine
I grew up in the kitchen with a
French kitchen an American kitchen in
a traditional Ecuadorian kitchen but they
never told me about Amazonian cuisine
so when I come to live in  pure
that I realize that there is a new
cuisine for me a new than an unknown cuisine
for that I had to go deep into the jungle
to really understand what
cooking is
[Music]
whenever there is a new product that
a person wants  they are going to try it for the
first time there is always a resistance
to the unknown
we give them to try the pure chanta that is
the worm from the Amazon
they see it c  as I dare I do not dare
but the moment they dare so
far has not been achieved we have not found
a person who tells us that the
blackass that the worm has seemed ugly to them
[Music]
blackmail is one of the
emblematic foods of  the amazon of ecuador
aside from that it is attributed
curative properties against the flu
with respiratory problems the
whole tentacle is something that may have
a somewhat different appearance but that
the taste is very good and above all the
nutritional contribution that it makes to the
person  Fortunately, throughout the
journey we have made in the Amazon,
nothing has stopped liking everything. For me, it
has been delicious.
I live convinced that Amazonian cuisine
must have the same
respect as the rest of the kitchens, they are
nutritious products and that we work
with  a good culinary technique can
be in any kitchen 5 stars